aux scouts dont j'avais 10 ans la cheffe
tête vous a offert des cartes de voeux
avec des représentations de santons de
provence la région où j'ai grandi et
noir les reçus et l'image du ravi qu'ils
allaient main levée devant la crèche
je n'ai pas forcément très fier de ce
cadeau j'ai été la voir on lui demandait
mais pourquoi elle m'a répondu ah non
mais ne soit pas vexer en fait ce
personnage est émerveillé tout y est
curieuse de tout tu es toujours à
l'affût et en fait profiter les autres
c'est justement pour te dire de
continuer comme ça en fait j'ai continué
je suis curieuse de tout et j'en ai fait
mon métier puis journaliste et je
m'intéresse au phénomène émergent dans
la société je m'intéresse aux signaux
faibles ces petites informations qui
mises bout à bout vont donner à sentir
verbaux de la société 20 il ya quinze
ans de jeunes américains qui s'échangent
les fichiers numériques musique cours en
toute illégalité en créant la bst r ça
c'était un signal faible dans les amplis
empêché de le faire mais résultats
quinze ans après l'industrie musicale
dans son entier a été bouleversé par ces
pratiques
alors c'est vrai qu'une grande partie
des signaux faibles vont restés
marginaux mais moi ce qui m'interesse
justement c'est de comprendre ce qu'ils
vont devenir fort et qui vont embarquer
la société et pour se faire au fil des
ans je me suis rendu compte qu'il
fallait que j'aille scruter les marges
les marges sociétal là où les
défricheurs ont assez d'espacé de
liberté pour imaginer de nouvelles
pratiques
alors comme je suis curieuse de tout je
me suis beaucoup cherché au niveau des
études j'ai fait en effet une école
d'ingénieurs une école de commerce donné
que le journalisme mais en fait on
enquêtant je m'intéresse c'est juge
empruntent ces différentes études comme
différentes portes pour enquêter le plus
largement possible
j'aime les pas de côté j'aime relier des
choses qui n'ont pas forcément de lien
entre eux pour poser un regard différent
et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas voir des
choses insoupçonnées
et justement il ya près de trois ans je
m'intéresse au bon coin à l'époque ya
déjà 17 millions de personnes qui vont
sur cette plateforme
je passe des jours à regarder les
petites annonces et je me dis qu'il se
passe quelque chose de sociétal je
demande aux dirigeants du bon coin s'il
accepterait d'ouvrir leurs données pour
que des experts puissent poser leur
regard sur la plateforme
il accepte d'où la surprise vient pas de
là c'est que je contacte des
intellectuels aucun ne connaît le bon
coin aucun ne s'y intéresse il y en a
même qui sont vexés que je les appelle
pour ce genre de sujet là pour rappel à
ce moment là les 17 millions de
personnes ou aussi bouleverser certains
grands secteurs d'activité puisque la
recherche d'emploi était bouleversé la
vente de véhicules d'occasion le marché
de l'immobilier donc 17 millions de
personnes qui passent inaperçues ça
c'est un sacré premier signal faible
et puis je continue à enquêter sur des
phénomènes émergents
l'utilisation du big data massive des
données personnelles
le fait que les gens vont commencer à se
prêter à mme en ligne on contourne dans
les banques
le fait que les jeunes par exemple se
disent s'engager dans la société
longtemps la lande des partis politiques
ou des syndicats mais en signant des
pétitions en ligne ou en misant de
l'argent dans le crowdfunding pour des
causes qui leur sont chères
en fait je découvre que ordinateurs et
smartphones en main mais citoyens sont
part du numérique pour agir pour
communiquer pour tester pour imaginer
pour entreprendre pour lire et en fait
pour une génération internet est devenu
une façon de se construire dans la
société et les experts que je contacte
me semble voir ça de façon assez
anecdotique
ils sont littéralement débordés par une
société qui ne les attend pas et ce
débordement je le constate dans
l'éducation dans l'économie dont la
politique dans la recherche alors le
cumul de toutes ces enquêtes
c'est un cumul de signaux faibles qui a
donné un signal fort donc je décide de
publier un long texte qui s'appelle les
élites débordé par le numérique
alors c'est vrai que je pars de la
définition du larousse élite groupes
minoritaires de personnes ayant dans une
société une place éminente du a
certaines qualités valorisé socialement
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
avant la publication de cet article je
me sens assez décalé en voyant quelque
chose qui me paraît évident qu'il n'est
pas forcément pour les gens qui
m'entourent
je me souviens ressentir une certaine
solitude en me disant que je parle pas
la même langue en fait en pointant du
doigt ce phénomène et puis l'article
sort et là c'est moi c'est moi qui suis
débordée par cet article des centaines
de milliers de pages vues sur le site du
journal
une communauté francophone et
francophile qui me dit que j'ai pointé
du doigt quelque chose au central dans
la société
en fait ce que j'ai vu il ya pleins
pleins d'autres personnes qui l'ont vu
des fois de façon totalement isolé des
gens qui ont envie de bouger les lignes
des défricheurs et qui voit cette
déconnexion alors je suis vraiment
impressionné par ce retour je me demande
quoi faire moi qui n'ai jamais écrit
deux livres je dis que je vais me lancer
donc je commence à contacter des
défricheurs et là une chaîne se met en
place
je pensais en contact et une trentaine
en fait j'ai donc contacté une centaine
parce que près de 4 chaque fois que je
contacter quelqu'un il me dit mais si
vous voulez parler de ce sujet là vous
vous appeliez intel aux états unis intel
en inde
intel en afrique du sud je me suis senti
porté en fait part ça c'était la
première fois de ma vie j'avais un tel
retour professionnellement et puis nous
le livre sort
il s'appelle la déconnexion des élites
comment internet dérange l'ordre établi
et le même phénomène va se produire mais
de façon démultipliée alors c'est vrai
que
dans le livre j'avais décidé d'une chose
c'est de ne donner aucun nom de ne pas
dire untel ne comprend pas ou untel ne
comprends pas ce qui m'intéressait
c'était d'expliquer que au delà de ces
signaux faibles multiples et mondiaux
nous étions dans un moment de
basculement un changement de
civilisation nous assistions à une
accélération du monde fulgurante par
rapport au temps de construction de la
société et que des nouvelles fortunes se
créent des nouveaux pouvoirs aussi
s'installe et que des questions
fondamentales éthique politique
géopolitique se pose alors je me
souviens en fait en écrivant la fin de
ce livre la conclusion réfléchir
justement à la dernière phrase est de
façon un peu utopique
j'écris au fil de mes enquêtes mon poste
journalistique est devenu une sorte de
plateforme dont la multitude signaux
faibles a commencé à faire sans ce
qu'ils pensent le monde qui vient qui
pose les limites 6e c'est ce débat que
j'ai envie de poser pour que les gens
s'en empare en fait on sait jamais si un
livre va être lui donc c'était plutôt un
voeu pieux et puis de fait les gens sont
saisis et de partout en france et m'ont
contacté pour que je raconte le monde
qui vient
non je me suis retrouvé devant des
assemblées extrêmement diverses tout
autant d des agriculteurs que des
experts comptables et des étudiants que
des syndicalistes des dirigeants que des
chercheurs ou des cabinets ministériels
alors à chaque fois que quelqu'un me
contacter je pose la question et qui a
qui ai eu l'idée
alors dans le cas justement de cette
première assemblée d'agriculteurs
c'était un agriculteur extrêmement
connectés qui se sentaient en décalage
avec les gens qui l'entouraient je suis
donc allé faire une conférence
j'ai parlé de la déconnexion j'ai parlé
du big data des questions éthiques
alors même qu'à l'époque monsanto venait
d'acheter une petite société de données
massifs pour analyser les semences
mondiale
et à la fin de la conférence est à un
grand dirigeant agricole qui lie à
prendre la parole et qui s'adresse à ce
défricheur qui en avait fait venir et
qu'il dit mais tu vois mon gars on
pensait que c'était un port sol quand tu
racontais des choses et puis ré écouter
madame bello et puis on se dit que
c'était peut-être nous étions hors sol
qui a vu des choses globalement que nous
on aurait peut-être dû voir j'ai été
extrêmement touché en fait part ce
moment d'autant plus que le dirigeant
était plutôt jeune et le défricheur
était plutôt moins jeunes alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya un clivage générationnel
on peut se dire que quand à 20 ou 30 ans
on a plus de chance de saisir le monde
qui vient et en fait l'âge ne fait pas
tout vraiment l'important c'est
l'ouverture
l'important c'est de comprendre
l'importance des signaux faibles pour
les caps tout pour son tour de gens qui
les cartes
j'ai été invité par un grand dans un
grand ministère par un haut
fonctionnaire qui m'a fait venir qui m'a
dit madame de l'eau vous parlez de
signaux faibles
moi quand je vois un signal faible dans
le discours d'un ministre joe beef parce
que ce n'est pas sérieux
expliquez moi alors je suis devenu au
fil des mois un chantre des signaux
faibles chaque fois que j'ai rencontré
un dirigeant quelqu'un qui s'occupe
d'une organisation qui va être en phase
avec l'époque je lui demande mais alors
qu'ils cherchent les signaux faibles
chez vous comment vous les attirer ces
personnes là et surtout comment vous les
protéger j'ai justement été contacté par
une personne on a recruté dans un grand
groupe français pyramidale pour faire
bouger les lignes pour aider le grand
groupe à se transformer à l'heure du
numérique
alors il a mis en place un écosystème de
start up pour que les petites startups
et les jeunes en irrigué l'entreprise
avec des idées la ville t
ça a l'air de plutôt bien fonctionné les
mais lui est très très malheureux et il
m'a dit qu'il allait quitter
l'entreprise et leur fille demander mais
pourquoi il m'a dit parce que moi me à
une plus un kiné comprends rien je lui
fais peur et il me met des bâtons dans
les roues
et puis par le plus grand des hasards
j'ai rencontrés sont très très grands
patrons dans un autre cercle de
réflexion et au cours d'une discussion
il me dit ben moi j'ai j'ai mis en place
comme ça j'ai des défricheurs qui font
bouger les lignes il parlait justement
de la personne qui m'avait contacté donc
j'ai gvt accès à 200 série t et entre
ces deux sincérité des courroies de
transmission bloqué parce que des peurs
se sont installés alors tout ça n'est
absolument pas nouveau les gens qui
pensent un peu en dehors des cases ont
souvent bien du mal dans la société il
ya des études et kid académique qui
suivent justement les enfants dans les
écoles primaires les enfants créatifs
sont souvent les moins bien notés alors
même que les instituteurs les
inspectrices disent que ce sont leurs
profils préférées et puis quand ces
personnes grandissent et qui rend dans
une entreprise ou une organisation c'est
un peu la même chose
leurs idées créatives sont souvent assez
mal à accepter quand bien même
l'entreprise annonce que la créativité
son objectif numéro un pourquoi tout
simplement parce que leurs idées apporte
de l'instabilité donc de l'inconfort
pour les personnes comme pour
l'organisation
mais le paradoxe c'est qu'actuellement
ce sont ce type de profil qui capte les
signaux faibles qui sont vitaux pour ces
structures pour qu'elle comprenne le
monde qui vient et ce sont justement ces
profils là de toutes générations qui me
contactent soit pour me raconter leur
vécu et souvent un peu leur problème
soit si long pouvoir pour que je vienne
les aider
autour d'eux à faire bouger les lignes
parce que le grand défi c'est justement
qu'ils aient un signe de liberté et de
sécurité pour que leurs idées puissent
être appliqués dans l'entreprise et et
c'est vrai que on voit bien que les
idées créatives pour qu'elles
grandissent souvent c'est par des
actions de commandos des gens qui sont
ensemble dans un coin qui se serrent les
coudes ou alors sous un protectorat
parce qu'on a quelqu'un deux ans au cas
très très envie que ça bouge et qui dit
surtout ne touchez pas ces défricheurs
je me suis posé la question
pourquoi le bon point est devenue la
première plateforme de recherche
d'emploi en france privée j'ai demandé
aux dirigeants du bon point qui m'ont
dit et en fait on ne sait pas grand
chose puisque nous on voit les annonces
arrivent et puis quand ces massifs on
met un onglet donc on a vu ces annonces
arrivent et ce qu'on a vu seulement
c'est que les entreprises d'intérim un
moment donné ont mis de façon massive
ces annonces donc je suis allé voir un
grand dirigeant d'une entreprise
d'intérim et je lui ai demandé mais
alors comment vous avez eu cette idée un
peu iconoclaste d'aller sur le bon coin
il m'a dit mme c'est pas moi c'est lui
des agences alors j'ai été voir une des
agences qui avait initié sain et le
dirigeant de l'agencé m'a dit mais c'est
pas moi c'est venu de jeunes et deux
stagiaires de jeunes et deux stagiaires
qui avait utilisé le bon point dans leur
vie quotidienne pour acheter des choses
qui étaient très satisfaits qu'ils sont
dit mais ça marche pour ça pourquoi ça
ne marcherait pas pour trouver des
intérimaires alors qu'on n'a pas assez
par pôle emploi est deux choses
intéressantes dans cette histoire d'une
part l'idée et par radio les débats et
deuxièmement la structure a eu assez
d'habileté d'intelligence collective
pour faire en sorte que cette idée ne
soit actuellement l'oeuf et qu'elle
puisse être généralisée à l'ensemble de
l'entreprise
il ya un et un grand grand serviteur de
l'état depuis des décennies qui est venu
me voir en me disant bonjour madame je
suis une élite déconnecté alors j'ai
débat non si vous l'étiez vous ne gagnez
pas et il m'a dit après un peu plus bas
c'est quelqu'un qui cherche beaucoup il
m'a dit comment comment vous avez vu ça
je reviens important c'est savoir d'où
on part là je suis journaliste donc un
journal plutôt élitiste dont de fait
d'une certaine façon
j'appartiens à ce monde là et c'est
justement en ayant un accès privilégié
favoriser haut de la pyramide sociétale
et en m'intéressant aux phénomènes
émergents et aux signaux faibles que
j'ai vu ce décalage croissant
c'est vrai que j'aime les pas de côté
que
j'aime sortir aussi des cases et c'est
justement en pouvant enquêter sur de
multiples secteurs que j'ai vu de façon
transversale cette déconnexion et que
j'ai décidé de l'écrire
alors c'était c'était une certaine prise
de risque de faire ça mais résultat moi
qui me sentais un peu isolé je me
retrouve avec une infinité de curiosité
et d'idées avec des personnes dans des
secteurs extrêmement extrêmement
différent plus j'interviens plus je me
rends compte que l'arrivée du numérique
dans nos vies soulève des questions
extrêmement intime pour chacun d'entre
nous la place et le statut qu'on a dans
la société
notre capacité qu'on va avoir à partager
un certain pouvoir accepter que des
idées viennent de là on ne les attend
pas la question de savoir ce qu'on va
pouvoir transmettre face à être
accélération du monde
ce que j'aime vivre avec ce livre et ce
qui en découle depuis est pour moi un
révélateur chacun j'en suis persuadé
d'où qu'il est dans la société peut voir
des choses que d'autres ne voient pas il
s'agit ensuite juste de trouver le bon
lieu le bon endroit pour en faire
quelque chose je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]